billionaire globalist corporations will
own everything homes factories Farms
cars
furniture and everyday citizens will
rent what they need now I want to show
you a video this is this is really
really good I was really when I saw this
I was like oh there are some other good
people out there that's nice to see uh
this is an Australian Senator his name
is Malcolm Roberts and listen to this
video just going off on clous Sha klous
Schwab and the world economic Forum as
per their great reset agenda which we've
talked about a whole a whole bunch about
and I think you can see how that's
related to everything happening in the
world right now instead of working
together to push CLA Schwab's World
economic Forum plan based on United
Nations policies work together instead
for our
country CLA Schwab's Life by
subscription quote is really surf them
it's
slavery billionaire globalist
corporations will own every everything
homes factories Farms cars
furniture and everyday citizens will
rent what they
need if their social credit score
allows the plan of the great reset is
that you will die with
nothing to pull off this evil plan Clash
Schwab's World economic Forum will need
to take more than just material
possessions from
Australians senators in this very
chamber today who support the great
reset threaten our privacy freedom and
dignity yes they're in this Senate
chamber so yeah people are waking up
they're waking up in the United States
guys like Elon Musk they're waking up in
Australia and and they are waking up and
we have to keep talking about this and
we have to keep exposing it and
everything else because as especially as
we roll into 2024 with this election
coming up whether it is a migrant crisis
whether whether it is Hamas rallies in
our cities whether it is covid and more
vaccinations and everything else whether
it is the internet going out and Donald
Trump's Doomsday Book or the crazy list
of things that we can think of and that
we cannot think of that are that are
unfolding right in front of us that
could be tossed right in our laps we
better be prepared you you better have
your head on straight otherwise whatever
is going to happen over the next year is
going to break you too if you're
watching this show you probably are not
broken yet like there are moments where
they could have broken all of us there
was a moment even in my life like two
years ago where we were considering
getting vac because of all of the
pressures right so they can break
everybody and and now we're in a real
pressure cooker situation because of
this election coming and you can just
feel it you can just feel everything
that we've just showed you the people on
our streets all the covid stuff like
it's just going to be a whacked out
crazy
year